Um, I'm, I'm such a sucker for a
specialist, whether it's a style vendor,
specialists who are striking
specialist or Damien Maia specialist.
I love watching the guys that
are like at the tip of the,
the ability in whatever their
disciplines, instyle, bender, man,
he seems to be getting better
every time. Yeah. Yeah.
Well for him it was just
about avoiding take downs.
Like he was so high level as a
kickboxer. He's so clever. Like he's,
he's like, in my opinion,
probably the very best in the
sport. It's setting traps.
He like gauge you see what you're
doing and it'll switch dances and some
information. Yeah. It's
not, it's not random.
And I liked the way he dealt
with the take downs. I mean,
he knows where he safe and where he's not,
you don't see that he's panicking.
He's like, yeah, it's got a minute and
let this cook a minute. But I seen him,
I seen with this attempt,
looks like,
I see what this one looks like
walking it through. All right,
now my party's going to start.
Yeah. Here's a guy I talked to,
one of his guys he trains with,
um,
I was referenced some
fights in China and uh,
it's one of the guys who trained with New
Zealand and this guy was telling me so
much and show me different things about
angles they do and things that they set
up in their striking that I had
never knew or thought about.
And this was before I saw him
start fighting in UFC. I, you know,
just everybody was aware of him but he
hadn't been in the UFC. Yeah. And Man,
these guys, these guys
are really smart. These,
the techniques like this sport is
growing so much, you know? Yeah, yeah.
That's what I was saying.
Like when you're seeing like really high
level super technical strikers like him,
like who's a worldclass lobbying as good,
he easily could be world champion in many
organizations as kickboxer to see him
now in the UFC and see guys having
to deal with that. It's like, okay,
this is like the Anderson fights a great,
great example.
We know how great Anderson is. Yeah.
And it's still look pretty good. Again,
style bender. But you could see why style
bender was special in that flight. He,
I'd like another level
of trickery. Yeah. Yeah.
And I mean and stuff John Jones
is doing. Yeah. Yeah. Well,
so you can't call him a specialist cause
man, he does so many different styles.
Right. It's like a, it's really
like a Kung Fu movie, right.
Where he changed styles. Yeah.
Yeah. And then they do they
do something. Yeah. Yeah.
Well John, such a good
kicker too. I mean that's,
that's interesting that he started
out as a wrestler. Cause like how,
how much of his style now is kicking you.
It's a giant part of his game,
his utilization,
those long ass legs and knees.
It's interesting like how,
how much time he did.
It looks like he's getting
information a lot. Right.
And then all of a sudden they have them.
Then when he shifts gears it's like,
okay, I've gotten a lot of information.
Here's what to do with it. Yeah. Yeah.
He's gonna Fight Tiago
Santos, right? Yeah. Yeah.
That guy goes for broke.
I mean he goes for broke.
It's interesting to watch him fight
because you want to talk about like a,
a wild reckless dude.
Like Santos is dangerous.
Uh, Jon Jones should and probably
will be a heavy favorite,
but Santos, he does w he
throws some, Hey, make no, no,
it's gonna be, it's going to be a,
it's a great fight to watch. Yeah.
That guy's going to go out on his
shield. No, he and he puts pressure.
I think the interesting thing about,
uh,
well for me with interesting when I
watched any of the heavier guys fight is
that they really have to understand where
they're safe and whether or not that's
something that John does really good.
How to be in the pocket and the
places where he's safe and you know,
knowing where he's, yeah, he's the
best Everett utilizing his reach.
Like no one's ever been
better at controlling reach
and then never letting a guy
reset. When guys try to reset Bam, he
kicks him, Bam. He kicks him again. Bam.
He kicks him again. He's like, he knows
when you're trying to get comfortable,
when you're trying to settle in,
and that's when he kicks you like ass.
Like he senses it. I just started to
battering you like you sees like, no, no,
no breaks, no brokers, no breaks, no
breaks, no breaks. Like the Anthony Smith.
What about a man? Um, Max Holloway.
Oh Dude, he's the king of no bricks.
Max Holloway is no break.
Oh, pours it on you.
He's just keeps coming.
Yeah.